well just about three years ago now we
started in this area called effective
computing which is designing systems
that are sensitive to your sentiments to
your moods basically and then react
accordingly the whole field that works
on this started just about really in in
seriousness ten years ago and I think
we're at the forefront in many ways in
terms of looking at what you do in
reaction to a user's mood so where we've
made a contribution is we can tell what
kind of mood you're in and we can
intervene on your behalf
maybe suggest something to do that it
like go take a walk take some deep
breaths get up and stretch those kinds
of things and some serious psychology
interventions as well and a new twist is
using pop culture and social media to
make you happier we are gathering data
from whether it's your arousal levels or
your heart rate and what we're trying to
do is communicate that back to people in
a way that makes sense a lot of times
this data comes back in massive forms
that people can't parse so we feel like
one challenge for us especially for me
as a designer is how do we translate
that data in a way that makes sense in
the context that they're experiencing it
and in ways that might cue other people
around them if that's needed so we
decided to explore the notion of
wearables and fabrics because that is
something that is a part of our
discretion every day so whether it's you
know a little thing that I might wear
them I light up or it's something very
dramatic and flamboyant it doesn't
matter to us and as as long as the it's
being communicated right whether they're
stressed are happy or so those are some
of the things that we're looking into
what are the benefits for a typical
person of the machine being able to
discern what emotions you're feeling at
given time well I think that one of the
biggest benefits is especially in
regards to stress is that often times
we're so disconnected with the fact that
we're experiencing stress because we
tune it out that these kind of
interventions whether it's a little poke
on my shoulder or something lighting up
can actually get us to pay attention for
a moment and and maybe get past that bad
habit so we think that that by getting
involved might actually like enhance
people
well being because they're so unaware of
what's going on we've actually been able
to show that in longitudinal studies
that we can make you less depressed we
can improve your positive coping
strategies and we think the reason we're
able to do this so well and so
accurately these days it's because the
ubiquity of sensors now they're cheaper
they're smaller they're more affordable
and they have longer battery life
they're still not perfect in that regard
and you have to remember to put them on
and take care of them and whatnot
but you know they can go places with you
so we can get very good using multiple
sensors at discerning various states
that we want to recognize like stress
mm-hmm and are you able to discern
between the things that would make a
heart rate go faster like between
someone jumps out at me and it's it's a
different feeling when I'm scared than
when I'm excited yeah I have adrenaline
in my system are you able to tell the
types of excitement and what what made
the heart go up or down it's an
excellent question that's that's been
our Holy Grail
yeah we're very good at getting arousal
levels from low to high but we want to
look at is valence from negative to
positive aspect and right now there are
various ways using you're looking at
your face listening to your voice where
you can start to discern those things
you can even analyze texts help the
system get better there's certain
pronouns for instance you use more when
you're when you're in a negative
affective state however we're really
still in the early days of this
technology in the science and which
which signals are going to be the best
to use in all contexts is still kind of
a it's a research problem and there are
also things around like even your phone
Laer accelerometer or your GPS how are
you running versus not yeah right so
that so there are cues that we can
borrow from other sort of sensing
mechanisms that can start to tell that
story and refine it but that is
something that is is research like we're
trying to hone in so that we can be
accurate yeah about what we're trying to
tell you I suspect if your heart rate
goes immediately up you know that's
probably you got scared probably got
scared
exactly also you graduated from Parsons
School of Design yeah a little bit about
your background there and how that
influenced your thinking so I yeah I
graduated with the bachelors in graphic
design and it was towards the end of the
90s and and that was right when
traditional design and digital design
sort of collided like
- sort of incoming and outcoming tides
and it really led me into more
interaction and web design and I started
in research actually in 1997 working in
virtual worlds technology so we were
building 3d worlds and designing them
and so my design background came in
handy because they were like well
imagine this kind of world or what would
this kind of world look like so from
there it's been sort of an ongoing
evolution of skillsets and understanding
how design can actually add to research
from different perspectives and offering
sort of new ways to sort of approach a
problem and Mary you have a PhD in
cognitive psychology a little bit about
that background well I was taught to
look at how people well we actually did
math models of how people process
information both visually auditorily how
we make decisions and when I came out of
school is the perfect time to do
human-computer interaction because it
was one single user who had to look at
the screen and make sense of it learn it
memorize it etc nowadays you know it's
more social psychology might be even
more relevant because you're looking at
groups of people using many systems
together but nonetheless because I
learned all these paradigms for how we
do work we're able now and in this new
research area to throw a lot of the ways
I did experiments back and back in the
old days throwing them at these new
problems like for instance when we use
the the fabric or the butterfly we had
to stress people out well I know how to
do that because I'm just like well let's
just so we have lots of ways of
examining this kind of problem right we
can really get you stressed out I can
make you depressed as well so and then
we have you know classic ways for
getting you back into a positive state
as well we never let you leave the lab
stressed out for instance but so those
paradigms that I was trained and
actually have come in quite handy and
obviously we have big data because we
have so many sensors we're using in this
work you have to know how to analyze big
data as well so my statistical
background comes in very high handy as
well and what are your thoughts on how
this will work in the future will you
keep your data from your body sensors
over a long period of time is that
people really like that right yeah and
we were just talking today I was just
out
north-western the last two days talking
to some clinical psychologists and we're
they really liked a system we built
called
affectaura which lets you reflect over
your moods over time and with the
population that those psychologists work
with being able to reflect over what
makes you happy what makes you sad in
your life is actually a very important
tool for mindfulness and and changing
behavior and what not so I think in
everything we build we probably will
allow you to keep your own database or
historical database of your effect
mm-hmm and can we talk a little bit
about some of the devices we have or we
see the the dress behind you we've got
the butterfly in front of you yeah tell
us a little bit about some of your
projects and what they do right okay so
this is our early prototype of mood
wings which is code we call mood wings
and and we used very simple nitinol wire
which actually moves when it gets heated
and so whenever the user was
experiencing a state of heightened
arousal the wings would start to flap
and so this was like our first prototype
we also have a second generation
prototype that actually uses speed of
the wings to sort of also map the
arousal levels so the more excited you
get the faster the wings go and we
actually did a couple series of studies
simulating a driving experience and you
know just seeing if users being aware of
their heightened state of stress how
they would respond to the butterfly
starting to move and it turned out
actually it did really stress them out
however they actually performed better
on their driving simulation so there's
something to be said for being aware of
your stress when you drive yes
additionally to that we have behind us
vesti so vesti is the actuated wearable
fabric and the notion with vesti was
really inspired by biomimicry and being
able to borrow cues from nature for
instance a porcupine or a dog or any
kind of animal with fur so when animals
are excited they often wag their tails
or they have mechanisms to sort of like
emote that and when they're upset the
hair tends to stand on end so vesti that
has been designed that with about 40
motors inside it
to flap and actually indicate happiness
when it flutters in front and hackles
when it when you're upset in the back so
it's very very over-the-top but
intentional because we believe that
wearables isn't just about one thing
it's about an expression it's about
something that lives on top of us as we
go forward so borrowing from our fashion
cues you know fashion will be responsive
so and with the vests see do you have
anyone with the talent to actually make
it do what they want or is it just kind
of it happens well I think the idea is
it would happen naturally right so
basically it would be in alignment with
the wearer yeah and it would just be
like an external emoting device and you
know often people say why would I ever
want that why would I ever want you to
know what I'm feeling and we think that
there are audiences that could benefit
from things like this like autism where
emoting is challenging or even how does
a parent relate to a child and there's a
communication gap there so if you have
these sort of fabrics that could relate
or respond maybe that facilitates the
communication or you might have PTSD you
like where outbreaks are possible how do
we create mechanisms that could you know
warn family members ok there's going to
be an eruption here these are kind of
things that we we hope that that even
something as fanciful as this could
maybe start to solve people might not
realize either they are remoting whether
they like it or not actually and I think
we make it obvious we think we might as
well get in touch with that right
because I think we suffer from the fact
that we are not quite in touch with how
we feel so it's called an honest signal
because you can't it's automatic you
can't really filter that out the other
place we found it very useful to have
something external to the user is for
instance in a doctor patient clinician
clinic visit where the doctor maybe sees
an expression of how warm or empathic
he's being or she's being the patient
doesn't even need to see it but the
doctor can kind of monitor oh you know
maybe I'm talking too fast we're working
with the Seattle Cancer Care Alliance
and some professors at the University of
Washington to maybe train oncologists to
be more
empathic or to have a better bedside
manner and and an external display is
actually quite useful in that scenario
all right Paul tell us a little bit
about yourself okay well I'm I'm Paul
I've been a developer in research for
about 10 years and the last few years
I've been in what we call affective
computing which we've been talking about
and it's it's probably the most
interesting set of projects I've ever
worked on in my life you know when I
started many many years ago in computer
science it was you know let's build an
accounting system and then I migrated
into let's build a web system and you
know that was exciting and now it's whoa
let's program it so a butterfly flaps
based on how excited you are yeah so
it's it's it's gone in a direction I
never would have guessed and it's it's
interesting it if it could possibly be
so when do you become involved in the
projects from the beginning oh I'm
involved yeah right from the start well
it depends on how you define the start
oftentimes you know a storm area will
come into my office and say something
like you know Paul we'd what if we had
you know this react to you know your
heart rate and I'll say that's that's
crazy
so if maybe I'm I'm after the initial
idea but I'm right at the start yeah and
what do you develop in it's a variety of
things it depends on whether I'm
building firmware onto a custom board or
whether I'm building an application on a
desktop or on the mobile phone or
whatever or in the cloud so I I do a
range from you know from firmware
software through c-sharp WPF
applications up to Windows Phone
applications Azure cloud storage
applications what are your biggest
challenges with this work oh the variety
you know it's I can't be an expert in
all of the technology from you know
writing sensor code to cloud code to
phone code so the variety is a challenge
it that's also the glory of it and and
the big thrill is because every day it's
a new challenge and it's a lot of fun
that way so what are some of the things
that you've worked on that surprised or
delighted you what were some of your
favor
well I did mention the butterfly the
butterfly was was a treat because like I
say it was a surprise to work on it you
know it's it's not every day that
somebody says you know can you make a
butterfly flap faster when you're
excited that is and and when you can get
it to actually work that's that's a
treat the vest also is is a fabulous
that was so much fun when you when you
build something and then show it to
people
and it reacts to their own emotions when
you when you when they're doing the demo
and you connected them to the device
it's a that's that is a thrill so tell
us about something that you've worked on
that surprised or delighted you yeah I
would definitely have to say the
printing dress the dress that I built
with a colleague of mine Sheridan Martin
small I was purely just exploration into
a what-if scenario what if your clothes
could actually display your thoughts
okay and so we use sort of Twitter to
kind of drive that and it was something
that we just thought we would do just to
sort of start communications around a
bigger conversation around wearables in
the company but what we didn't expect is
for everyone else outside of the company
to respond to that and the attention in
the press so that got was unprecedented
at least from my experience I have never
experienced that before and it ended up
in bloomingdales
so that was totally like unexpected but
what was nice about it was that it was
validating in that people did resonate
with it and they understood the concept
of it and that was the goal of it was
really just to inspire people to think
beyond just a device that you know
sensors and actuators together
eventually will change a lot of how we
express ourselves in the future or even
understand things about ourselves so
health sensing is a big topic right now
I mean I'm wearing a Fitbit right now
and what are the types of things that
you see this doing for people in the
health sense going forward and where do
you think this will take us in the
future so we just came off a big
four-week study where we had users do
self ratings of their mood
for us and then we used machine learning
techniques to try to figure out their
context I'm using things available on
the phone but also their self ratings of
emotional state and then we could go
ahead and intervene and we tried all
kinds of different kinds of
interventions to help them feel better
emotionally and health-wise and it turns
out that we got significant decreases in
depression and significant benefits from
using machine learning to help teach
them positive coping skills so I think
in the future the masses are actually
are going to have access to information
about their emotional state which and
hopefully tools that they can learn to
use to make themselves feel better
emotionally not just fitness wise but
emotionally because you know stress for
instance is a killer it really is a
killer the more I read about stress I
always get stressed out because it's
just really so bad for your health so I
think the future holds a lot of promise
in that regard but if we talk about
targeting populations of people who
really need this you know people with
depression people with serious stress
problems people who emotionally eat PTSD
people families with PTSD or ADHD we can
make a huge difference in their lives
with some of these applications we're
working on source super-excited about
that I think also in terms of form
factors everything is going to get
smaller and exponentially I mean even
two years out we may not even see the
sensors were wearing I we already are
aware of some of the e tattoo work
that's coming out of MC 10 and so these
kind of things just open up all sorts of
crazy doors and and so it isn't going to
be these chunky devices I mean soon
enough it'll be integrated into our
person so they'll be embedded so I see
you've got a MakerBot 2 back here yeah
tell us a little bit about that and what
are you using it for so what we just got
this recently um I was inspired to get
one of these for a few reasons one is
because the PLA and the filaments they
can be bendable as well as conductive
and I thought there's a really
interesting intersection between fibers
and fabrics and these filaments so I
thought that could be some interesting
explorations that happen there
but additionally I mean there are
already numerous examples of dresses
that you actually like like attached
together their shoes and hats I mean so
as far as the accessory world goes it's
kind of endless so I I just have this
innate fascination with the fact that I
can just print something out just like
that it's kind of mind-blowing it makes
me feel like we're back we're now in
Star Trek right now it's like computer
coffee
so instead I would say computer shoes so
I I think it's just it's it's for now is
we're kind of at the beginning of
looking into it but it's been a lot of
fun what are some of the other tools
that you use typically I'm so typically
I mean I I've worked with like
conductive threads and fabrics and ei L
fabric and so sort of all sort of soft
circuitry to play with I've also worked
with a loom believe it or not and I've
woven my own sort of interactive textile
so I think it's just whatever comes
along at the moment that's needed is is
kind of the stuff we play with so we're
we're open so right now we're doing
conductive ink on acetate and the
playing with some stuff like that so
it's hard though it's really hard to put
these systems together there's so many
moving parts you know you have to be an
expert in sensors signal processing
machine learning materials psychology
and design yeah it takes a small village
seriously to do this work how durable
are the items that you build I mean
they're promised you know to be honest
they're not very this is where we're at
mean things are crude wires are clunky
sticking you know power the issue of
power is a huge one like batteries and
being able to continuously sense it
requires a lot of power so there are all
sorts of things I have to happen on
those levels to to actually get us past
the clunky phase you run in one of our
experiments the care and feeding that's
involved we did one study with a bra a
woman's bra that they had to keep taking
off every four hours because they had to
charge the charge across batteries and
charge the sensors they were wearing
that and intended Heisey so yeah so like
I said I mean we we're still at early
phases but this is why it's really
exciting because we don't know what sort
of impact is gonna happen when
when something in whether it's the
material sciences or the electronics
something changes that fundamentally
conductive charging alone exactly I mean
being able to gather you know energy and
power from your body
I mean we're getting we're going to get
there yeah it's exciting well thanks so
much for showing this us today yeah
thank you for having us